all right we're breaking news the FBI is
reopening its investigation into Hillary
Clinton's email into the private server
that she used into the possibility that
she sent classified emails as well we do
have a letter confirming that from FBI
director James Comey we're also going to
bring in Margaret talev now from
Washington DC she's our senior White
House reporter Margaret I know it's a
it's a fast breaking story but vani
points out this must be all due to the
WikiLeaks releases is that the catalyst
for this that's the theory that we're
operating under at that at this point it
makes the most sense and ten days out
from the election the one thing we know
for sure is this is certain to have some
level of political repercussions in a
race that has already tightened the FBI
and congressman Chaffetz all divulging
not as much information as we want at
this point we know that this is reopened
but not how big a deal it's going to be
whether this is huge or whether it's
sort of pro forma and Comey doing what
he needs to do for the sake of Justice
and credibility
we certainly expect a wide reaction from
Republicans all the way from Donald
Trump to down-ballot members we
certainly expect the Clinton campaign to
have to respond but just how big this
impact is going to be we don't yet know
yeah and we don't want to overreact
because we don't know what it is yet we
just have an investigation that's being
reopened presumably an investigation
takes a while could it run past the
election day yeah I mean I think in this
sort of thing when you're up against a
sort of a deadline it is always going to
be the desire to the interests of the
investigating body to move as quickly as
they can but to show that they have done
a thorough job in considering the
details
literally this story is unfolding within
the last few moments so we hope to have
a little bit more information but I
would certainly expect that that the
investigators that the FBI is going to
want to move as quickly as they can to
kind of sort of contain political
fallout from this and keep us to sort of
adjust the facts sort of procedure of
easier said than done with literally a
week and a half left on the race we do
have Margaret I just want to bring up
the letter
got it here on my Bloomberg from James
Comey to members of Congress in the last
paragraph he does say although the FBI
cannot yet assess whether or not this
material may be significant I cannot
predict how long it will take us to
complete this additional work so I think
it's important the time frame here to
take that into account and I also think
in the second paragraph he says in
connection with an unrelated case the
FBI has learned of the existence of
emails that appear to be pertinent to
the investigation so that seems to I'm
not sure if the FBI is working on any
cases involving WikiLeaks but he says
they've received this information in can
in connection with an unrelated case
very interesting right well and we do
know because John Podesta has told us
himself that the FBI let him know that
they were going to they were in the
process of conducting a criminal
investigation into the hacking of his
account his gmail account so it's
entirely possible that that's what this
is connected to and it's entirely
possible that they're not going to be
any stunning revelations from this but
this is a matter of the investigating
body doing due diligence and checking
all the boxes are there any precedents
for a candidate having to withdraw for
any reason either before the election or
during a lame-duck session for the the
you know the the the president-elect to
have to withdraw the the position leave
the position you're saying is there any
precedent for that I I think we're not
nearly far enough along in this process
to know whether any of that's even going
to be in play but I certainly think that
I would expect the opposition both the
Trump campaign and the Republican
down-ticket candidates to be making the
most of this until there's some reason
why they should not and I think this is
the last thing Hillary Clinton's
campaign wanted in the closing week